hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round six of this
year's Global chess League it is Yang
shisht of Duda versus vishwanathan Anand
but before we check out the game uh and
yes it is the Ganges Grand Masters
versus the chingari golf Titans board
one uh there is some news from the Chess
World uh there is uh new information on
the lawsuit um uh Han smoke and Iman uh
filed against the Magnus Carlsen and
some other prominent people in the Chess
World uh basically uh this is uh people
are sharing it all over Twitter so I'm
just gonna read it out it's the title
from The Wall Street Journal Journal a
federal judge dismissed a claim by the
USGS Grandmaster against former world
champion Magnus Carlsen and others over
allegations that Neiman had cheated in
competition so there you have it if I
know more I will I will share with you I
don't know if you can appeal
you know a claim but uh you know if you
can I will inform you guys now getting
back to the game uh Duda already lost
the Anand in round one it was a very
nice game we've shown in Channel if you
haven't seen it also you can check it
out so now do that will do a very much
like the uh well beat Anand with the
white piece so let's see the game uh
Duda opens with fantasy for he goes for
the English opening we have C5 Knight to
F3 Knight to F6 so going symmetrical for
the moment and B3 and okay we have
pawned the E6 by Anand Bishop to B2 Pawn
to D5 now striking in the center uh
transfer posing into the ashinkur
defense with G3
uh and Knight the C6 we have a trade on
the five captures captures and the
bishop to G2 now dude that wants to slow
play this he fionkeros both of his
Bishops we have Pawn to D4 uh Anand
grabs more space in the center and now
castles with Bishop of the E7 uh also
preparing the castle and pawn to E3 now
and here okay you are putting pressure
on D4 and you are sort of inviting D3
and it seems like like a move you really
want to play because you you kind of
style a stifle blacks uh development and
also continuation of the game for
example you can maybe uh put a develop
the Knight to C3 put a queen on B1 put
pressure on that pawn maybe also attack
it with the Knight maybe uh with the
bishop so it's hard to uh you know long
term it's hard to decide whether this is
good or not uh so yeah of course it is
not play it has only been played once
before and black actually won uh but not
quite at this level
uh so instead just castles uh Knight to
A3 and now D captures on E3 okay D
captures on E3 and there is a game where
Queen to C7 was played was played uh 19
years ago in 2003 uh is sorry in 2004
before between uh Joseph Horvath and
Constantinople and lublesk who won this
game very nicely uh but here we have
Bishop to F5 first and it is now uh as
of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game so okay Knight to C4 Duda
continues improving his pieces we have
Queen to C7 and now Knight after E5
offering a trade of knight uh as the
bishop also controls that E5 Square very
nicely rotate at the eight attacks the
queen queen to E2 gets the queen out of
the way also connects the Rooks and now
we have a trade Knight captures on E5
and do that chases away the Queen Bishop
captures an E5 with Queen to C8 and now
Rook F to D1
uh nicely opposing The Rook on d8 uh
Bishop to G4 you could also consider
maybe some other moves but Bishop to G4
is just very annoying you're asking
white uh what will y do here of course
you are not expecting Bishop to F3 so
the question is whether you're gonna
trade on d8 first or you will you will
weaken your King's position with F3 uh
dude I'm not afraid he goes for Pawn to
F3 and now Anand goes back Bishop to E6
uh the problem with Bishop H3 here is
that um well there are all sorts of
nasty moves that do that can play like
Knight to D6 for example attacks the
queen and now if you trade let's say
captors captures uh what do you play now
the The Rook is hanging Rook fd8 now
your capture on H3 and you lose the C5
Pawn uh so there's that so that's why
after F3 Anand goes back Bishop to E6
and now Knights to D6 but okay now it's
not as scary now and we'll just uh
defend with uh Pawn to B6 so Bishop
counters Bishop characters Rook after E8
and now Rook 8 to C1 putting pressure on
the C5 pawn and now Pawn to B6 and while
I'm sure you guys are expecting Pawn to
be for here uh do that first play spawn
to E4 uh we have Bishop to H3 and only
Now Pawn to B4 makes sense as uh the the
queen is occupying the same file as The
Rook uh Bishop captures on G2 Queen
captures and now
uh Pawn to C4 uh this is one way to do
it the other way is Rook to E6 Rook D6
is also a very nice move point being
that now the bishop is hanging and after
a trade happens here let's say captures
captures uh no what do you would you
play the bishop is hanging Bishop to F4
you trade a pair of Rooks let's say
captors captures and now you start
advancing the the past C Pawn so uh also
and another bad way to go uh Anand
decides to do it right away he plays
Pawn to C4 we have Pawn to E5 uh
advances the pawn and also chases away
the Knight Knight the D7 and now Pawn to
F4 now if you can get uh the other Pawns
of the those other Pawns of the board
could be very hard for Anand to defend
this but he just goes B5 now the C4 Pawn
is beautifully defended uh Rook to D5
and now we have Pawn to A6 we have Rook
C the D1 uh do they using the fact that
the B5 Pawn was undefended a sort of a
double up without wasting time on the D
file Knight's the B6 chases away The
Rook Rook to D4 and now Knight the A4
now anand's plan is of course Knights
the B2 and then uh put the the Knight to
C3 or if the White Queen remains there
to defend the B2 Square then maybe you
can even start advancing the C Pawn
right away so Duda decides uh you know
uh uh for Queen to F3 and now as the B2
square has been vacated for the Knight
Knight to B2 now the Knight is coming to
D3 and it's either gonna remain there
for pretty much forever it's a light
Square uh dude only has a dark Square
Bishop but you know since dude allowed
it uh you know that he will be
sacrificing The Exchange on D3 uh for
that night so Rook one to D2 and now
Knights to D3 and he doesn't wait for it
he just captures it the problem with uh
keeping the Knight on D3 is that what do
you play like you play Four okay you
want to create some weaknesses here C3
even can be played you can even
sacrifice the Knight and he throw
captures C2 how are you stopping the
pawn there's only one way to do it Rook
to C3 you will advance the pawn now the
queen comes into the game captures
captures with the check and okay now you
play something let's say Rook D1 Queen
to C2 the game continues but uh black
will always be better so that's why
Doula decides to do it right away Rook 2
captures on D3 C captures and queen
captures on D3 he's now done the
exchange but he's up upon and okay this
uh pawn bishop um uh barricade that he
placed here on on E5 and D6 is
definitely keeping those Rooks at base
so if Anan can somehow utilize the C
file uh for his uh Rooks then okay good
things might have and otherwise the
bishop um uh definitely has a
compensation over the sacrifice exchange
so Queen to C1 with check we have came
to G2 and now Queen to B2 with check uh
now uh Queen to D2 although uh Duda
probably knows uh that this is the best
move it doesn't uh offer over that much
chances to him so he goes King to H3 but
this is not much much um uh more
dangerous now comes Rook D6 and now Duda
has to trade Queens otherwise Rook dh6
check comes with an attack on the H2
pawn and it's gonna be resigned so Queen
to D2 uh the movie you kind of have to
play right away with Rook to H6 check
King to G2 and now Rook uh Queen
captures on D2 here and could also just
play Queen B1 and prepare some sort of a
rook to see to see two scenario uh where
it will be hard for Duda to defend
because Duda is much lower on time than
Anand but he decided to trade Queens uh
Queen captures Rook captures and now
Pawn to F5 aren't very much confident
that he will not have any problems here
and if Duda does not play a perfect game
he might even win this so Pawn to H3 uh
we have Rook to G6 we have King to F3
and Ponte H5 stopping that G3 Pawn where
it stands and now uh it's gonna be hard
for the king to get into the game
as the G3 Pawn will be a permanent
weakness here so Rook the D5 and now uh
okay Anand would of course enjoy putting
his works on the C file but here uh Duda
would just contest The Rook would work
to C5 and you can't really trade even
though you're up material because now
the two uh the two pass pawns will be
maybe a bit too much for for The Rook to
handle so instead Rook D5 we have rooked
the E6 uh and now Pawn to G4 uh Ananda
moves the roof from the G file allows G4
but it's the only way to move the game
forward so Pawn to G4 and it is the best
move for Dura so let's go for it
captures captures Pawn to G6 and now
Pawn to G5 and okay this is a beautiful
blockade the Rooks are uh helpless
against the bishop here but now Anand
has the open C file and the open Age
file to use to his advantage and the two
Rooks will do just that so here we have
Rook E38 uh we have a rook the D1 and
now uh King to F7 we have Pawn to A4 try
trying to create some weaknesses here
King the E6 the king is remarkably safe
here uh eight characters a captors now
the a file opens up as well and now all
of these open files don't really uh
uh go and do this favor uh because well
if someone loves the open file it's
definitely The Rook so King te3 and now
Rook the AHA the first Rook occupies the
uh the open H file and now you can try
fighting a little bit okay uh or maybe
Rook Day One controls day file then if
the row comes to the C file then maybe
you can hold the C file with the bishop
but here King the D4 was played and now
Anan is completely winning uh he only
has one chance to do it but now I'm I
fear I might have spoken too loudly I'm
sure you guys already know what I'm
talking about but just in case uh feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Anand while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook the C8 uh it it's okay I know it
looks like just you're occupying the uh
open C file and you might be thinking
but why not Rook the A8 this uh keeps
the a file occupied uh so maybe we can
harass the white king this way but then
you allow the white king up the board so
it's a very much different Rook to C8
completely uh leaves the white uh
defenseless and there's just no way to
to handle all the pressure Rook to see
for check is coming and then the two
Rooks will uh finish the job very
quickly so Bishop to C5 he he tries it
uh he tries to hold the the C file but
now uh the D file opens up so here we
have Rook H to d8 with check uh Bishop
back to the sixth and now of course we
Rook to see for checking the E3 but now
Anan just shifts The Rook back to the H
file Rook to h8 we have Bishop to C5 but
not his game over Rook to HD 3 with
check King to F2 Rook captures an F4
with check no way to defend this King to
G2 and now Rook to B3 we've rooked the
D6 with check King to F7 sorry not King
to F7 King captures and E5 much better
uh and now Rook captures on G6 and here
Rook the G4 with check uh we have King
to F2 uh Pawn to F4 now and then starts
advancing his pass pawn and now Rook to
G8 we have rooked to beat you with check
uh now if you go up the board King F3
then Rook to G3 is mating one so King to
F1 was played and now Rook to H4 and he
was in this position and move 59 that
Yang shisto Duda resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you uh of course The Rook to H1
will be checked yes it's not Checkmate
you can block with the bishop but then
Rook to B1 check will win that piece so
you could play King to G1 but now let's
say King T4 and once you play any move
then comes King to F3 now all of the
squares have been taken in front of the
white king next move is Checkmate uh so
you know you prolonged for a move or two
but that's pretty much it so of course
uh Duda knows this and then move 59
after this
um uh wonderful uh uh Rook to be to
check do the resigned and as of course
sorry after Rook to H4 he resigned as
there is nothing more to be done here so
a great game by Anand beating Duda not
once by but twice in this uh tournament
which also means that uh well
unfortunately for anan's team uh his
team lost uh even though he won on board
one but the Anand is the the the the
best board one in the tournament so far
he's on four and a half out of six so
that is absolutely incredible even with
one loss that one loss that we've shown
to Magnus Carlsen uh next game on
displaying Magnus again and he will have
a chance to retaliate so we'll see what
happens there and yeah he's on four and
a half out of six I think mamidaro is on
four out of six Magnus and The Duda and
the other side on three and a half out
of six so Anand really just having a
beautiful beautiful event and just
destroying everyone so there you have it
uh I hope you guys enjoyed it uh and
yeah if you guys want to get
notifications faster if YouTube is not
doing you justice then we do have a
telegram Channel first link in the
description below do join us sometimes I
even uh you know uh wish you we should
wish you a happy morning or you know
maybe uh if it's Christmas I will I will
write happy Christmas but mostly I just
you know notify you when uh when a new
video is up so yeah uh that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Thomas vetterly uh about this uh
uh business uh Federico Torres
Dan McCormick and James Eugene Cashman
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day